[Music]
since Russia's Invasion began drones
have been at the Forefront of the battle
tonight the Kremlin seeing the biggest
drone attack yet inside Russia Ukraine
says it's ramping up the Homegrown
production of drones and in the face of
overwhelming odds Ukraine has had to
adapt with an army of volunteers
supplying an estimated 90 of the
country's military drones
videos
[Music]
this is how the Russian invasion created
a drone Revolution
[Music]
in the face of Russia's Superior
long-range missiles an iranian-supplied
Kamikaze drones Ukraine turned to an
army of volunteers
um
[Music]
not sure
um
ego and his brother Vitale print 3D
parts to turn consumer drones into
deadly weapons
[Music]
materials to build their Fleet of attack
drones come from unexpected sources
[Music]
crane started the war with a three to
one advantage in tactical drones
but with the two sides now at parity the
need for DIY innovation has never been
greater
International and domestic backers are
raising serious money
Ukraine's biggest volunteer group come
back alive raised 155 million dollars
last year alone
200 drone startups Now operate across
the country
[Music]
um
foreign
prototypes attacked the Russian base in
Crimea
for more more Russians the war is coming
closer to home
that same week ukrainians use DIY
cardboard drones to damage five Russian
fighter aircraft
Ukraine has had to adapt to survive but
the resulting innovation in drone
Warfare has revolutionized the conflict
is
thanks for watching if you'd like to see
more from Economist films please click
the link and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]